60% or 80% of the activity
that goes on in your brain
is about deciphering visual data
and visual input that you get.
There are scientists who've done
a tremendous amount of research on this,
and it's within 13 milliseconds
that you know what a picture is of.
You can look at a blurry picture
and you'll know it's a bedroom,
or a kitchen, or a street scene.
You don't need to see detail.
The power of photography
is way more complicated
than people admit to.
And I think there's psychological
and physiological reasons
that we respond to things
that we respond to,
as well as intellectual
and emotional ones.
So it's wildly complicated
and it's terrific.
It's great, it's great.
I loved the title of your book,
Photography Changes Everything,
because of course it does.
And I thought maybe we'd start
with talking a little bit
about that project.
I spent about three years
reaching out to almost 100 people,
asking them to think how photography
changed what they did,
because I was very interested
not in the power of images
as museums often talk about them,
but in terms
of the consequentiality of images
and how they really transform things.
I was sitting in a room with a bunch
of environmental scientists
surrounded by drones.
Actual drones in the room?
Yeah, drones were all there
on shelves, right?
And we were talking
about the project they were doing,
and they were showing me
the kind of schematic God's-eye view
down through the drone's flight path
where you could look at every image
that the drone made,
and each drone
was making 2,000 images a day,
and that was all really interesting.
But I turned around and I looked
to the people in the room,
thinking about Edward Steichen
and aerial photography,
and I said, “Does anybody here
ever think about the history
of aerial photography
as you're doing this?”
And they said, “No.”
–Right?
–Right.
And I thought, well,
that's a really interesting thing.
I mean, photography for the people
in that room was a tool.
They didn't care
about the history of it
and what got them
to where they needed to be
in terms of images.
Photography is used by everybody,
and everybody uses it
for all sorts of reasons,
and images can be beautiful
and useful for all sorts of reasons,
and consequential
for all sorts of reasons.
Do you think it's important
to tell a history of photography
or do you think that
that is sort of a 20th century goal?
I think it's hugely important to talk
about the history of the medium
because it's not
quite a universal language,
and the idea that we're all
visually literate is not quite true.
We can all probably
extract some very basic level
of information from photographs
but I think you have to learn
to understand how images work
and how images are constructed.
Who made the picture,
why did they make the picture,
who edited the picture,
who cropped the picture,
who captioned the picture,
what pictures did they leave out,
what pictures are being censored?
It's a malleable medium,
and I think people
need to be aware of that.
That's one of the big goals
in visual literacy is for people
to understand how many different ways
you can make and use
and understand any kind of image.
There's nothing like it,
there's no other experience like it
because when we're
walking around the world,
you don't have time
to see everything around you.
For a moment,
you can stop something
and look at it in a way
that you normally wouldn't see it,
and I think that's part
of the real fascination
with still photography.
It's a kind of very existential,
philosophical kind of medium.
It lets you step outside yourself
to kind of look at the world
in a different way.